the war is over you know most of us have
given up most of our privacy already if
you are giving or all of your financial
disclosures online your credit card your
social security and so forth I think the
way we protect those things can provide
afford us the ability to protect our
medical records as well it's moving in
this direction in fact one would say
there is almost a moral obligation for
people to begin to disclose at least a
portion of their medical records online
because it's only through that
disclosure on a large scale whether it's
you're not your Nestle your name and
your identity but at least you're
finished your phenotypical data and your
genomic data will allow us to create a
whole revolution and personalized and
preventive medicine which i think is uh
which is extraordinarily important for
the next few decades we are testing what
it is like to lose privacy now the loss
of privacy inherent in these
technologies is a precursor to an almost
biological or extra sensory loss of
privacy that will come as the species
evolves shame that could be used to
control us will no longer be able to
control us because we'll find out that
everybody masturbates err everybody has
this kind of sex with their with their
spouse or eats this kind of food or
picks their nose or does whatever a lot
of taboo won't be taboo anymore and that
which is truly taboo will kind of rise
to the surface in a way and we'll see
well we all can kind of agree that we
don't want to do this if the species
survives will will develop that sort of
organismic capability and we won't be
able to be embarrassed by that stuff
anymore
you